what were some of the biggest writing
mistakes you made in the beginning of
your screenplay writing and how did you
realize they were mistakes I think the I
think it's a good question what are the
mistakes I made all sorts of mistakes
when I was starting to write but you
know I think I don't necessary think of
them as mistakes and more it's like I
think it's just the process of learning
you know and and I'm happy that I that I
was able to you know have the time to
just keep writing and writing and
writing things that jump to mind when I
think about like my particularly
mistakes I think one I was a little
scared of trusting my own point of view
I think I was relying too much on the
models of screenwriting you know looking
at books on the hero's journey and
three-act structure and and you know now
you know some of the more of also I was
just I was obsessed with those things I
was trying to find an answer in them and
at the end of the day like I do think
that they have some use but no for me I
realized when I just let go of that just
ask myself like just core emotional and
dramatic questions first of all actually
sometimes it would result in stuff that
actually had that structure anyways
inherent in it and even when it didn't
it still worked so definitely like the
sort of avoiding the structure I think
honestly also not outlining and spending
enough time planning there's such a
temptation to feel like you're not
getting anything done until you type on
the page and I feel like if anything
what I've learned in every time I write
a screenplay I think I now spend longer
in the brainstorming and then outlining
phase each time realizing that it's so
easy to think I just type the scene like
that means I made progress but if it's
not the right scene not the right entry
to that scene not the right character is
not the right time that time doesn't
really get me anywhere and so I'm really
trying to like and it's hard to do that
it's hard to stay in the brainstorming
phase because it can feel like oh my god
I'm not making progress quite literally
we use page count as like our metric of
progress I wrote five pages today and I
do think that that is I think in some
ways like destructive to creativity like
sitting there are times which like I
have sat for an hour staring out the
window and had no good thought so the
final two minutes but that one idea was
so good shapes the whole film that that
hour that the 58 minutes where I didn't
think of anything was worth that two
minutes those two minutes might be worth
weeks of right
just to have that right sort of you know
brainstorm so for sure I think I rushed
too quickly into writing pages was
another mistake I made and then lastly I
really do believe it's related to
outlining I don't think you should start
writing the movie until you know the end
I think the end of a movie is so
important because it shouldn't for my
everything comes before it I think it's
in some ways no matter whether you're
making a super clear movie or someone in
biggest movie whatever the ending is
it's you know in the classic setup up
like a joke if that's the punchline the
setup has to be right for it and I think
writing any pages before you know where
that's coming is a mistake even if your
ending is open-ended I think you need to
know your leading to that and so until I
know the end I won't start writing
you